-My first guest tonight is
a very funny comedian
who you know from
"Saturday Night Live."
He and Jon Stewart
are putting on a show called
"NYC Still Rising After
20 Years: A Comedy Celebration"
this Sunday
at Madison Square Garden.
Tickets are available now.
Everyone, please welcome
Pete Davidson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Pete Davidson ♪
♪ Ain't no mystery ♪
♪ Pete Davidson ♪
♪ Simply can't compare ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-They love you.
-Very cool.
-That's some love.
That's some love for
Pete Davidson right there.
-It's a full crowd.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Right.
-Oh, wow.
-Thank you for being here.
I appreciate you coming back.
-Thanks for having me.
-"SNL" had a great season
last year.
You had had
a great season, as well,
so congrats again on that.
I wanted to ask you a question,
though, because there was
an episode where I know --
I knew you were
friends with him.
But it was
Machine Gun Kelly and you
are at the end of the show,
at goodnights,
and you're kind of
hugging and celebrating.
And then
you fall off the stage.
-Yeah.
-What was going --
What's the real story?
What happened?
-So, Colson -- or as you may
know him as Machine Gun Kelly --
he bruised his coccyx that week.
If you don't know what a coccyx
is, it's the bone in your ass.
-Okay. Oh, okay. Yeah.
-Yeah, it's from --
If you've ever seen
"Napoleon Dynamite,"
Uncle Rico says,
"Grandma took
a spill at the dunes.
She broke her coccyx."
Yeah.
-That's a good reference.
-So, I thought he was joking.
He was like,
"I broke my coccyx."
-He broke his coccyx?
-Or he bruised it.
And I was like, "Oh, that's..."
He was like, "No, for real."
So he couldn't,
like, walk or sit
and he had, like,
a tushy pillow that he was --
It was just really cool
to see, like,
the most
gangster, thug dude I know
just, like, put a little tushy
pillow down and, like, sit.
-Inflatable ring.
-Yeah, it's just, like,
Megan Fox is right there,
and he's sitting on
his little tushy pillow.
So, he was like,
"For goodnights,
we should do something,
you know, silly."
And I was like, "Or, you know,
you could just
enjoy the moment and clap."
-Yeah.
-And he was like,
"No, we'll think of something.
I'm going to,
like, pick you up."
I was like, "I don't know
if you should do that.
It's a crowded stage.
You know, we should just clap."
And he's like, "Yeah, yeah,
you're right."
And he got really excited
and he went to pick me up
and he forgot that he had
a bruised coccyx.
So he, like, went to pick me up,
and then he couldn't go up,
so he just started to
slowly tilt back.
And he went --
he went, "Oh, no."
And it was such a slow fall,
we had time for him to go,
"Oh, no," and I went,
"You're a [bleep] moron."
And --
-It was that slow of a fall.
-It was that slow.
I got the full line out.
-Also, you're a big dude.
-We're both pretty tall dudes.
-Yes.
-And we have no, like --
It's hard to pick me up,
'cause I'm so, like,
flimsy and bony.
So, like, yeah, it was --
-I have a clip.
-Oh, great.
-I want to show everyone.
Here's Machine Gun Kelly
trying to pick Pete up on "SNL."
Take a look at this.
-Yep.
♪♪
-Dude, I was like, "Yo!"
-Yeah.
-That was --
-And then they
cut right after that.
They went right to --
they went right to
whatever the next thing was.
So, I went to -- Nobody ever
texts me during a show.
I went back,
there was like 40 texts like,
"Yo, you alive?"
Yeah.
-That was so funny, dude.
-Yeah.
-Last time you were on the show,
we were talking about
"Suicide Squad" and "SNL,"
and I think I remember you
telling me that you got a dog.
And I was like,
"That's awesome."
-Yeah.
-Congrats on that.
-Thank you.
-Yeah. And then --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's a big deal. Yeah.
-And now you came back here
and you just told me,
backstage --
You go, "Hey, dude,
everything's cool.
I just got a dog."
And I go, "Yeah,
you told me that already."
-Yeah, I got three dogs during
the pandemic, 'cause it's hard.
No, I got the first dog,
like, for me,
but I had to leave
and go do something,
so it had to stay with my mom.
And then, when I came back,
the dog was, like,
really tight with my mom.
Like, more --
Like, it wasn't as excited
to see me as it was my mom.
So I bought another one.
-Yeah.
-And then,
same situation happened,
where I had to go away
for a little bit,
but I was like, "Can't leave it
with my mom, 'cause she --"
-No. You saw what happened.
-Yeah, I saw what
happened to the first one.
So I gave it to my sister,
'cause she's less lovable
of the Davidsons.
No, I'm just kidding.
She's wonderful.
She actually just got her coat.
She got coated.
She's, like,
a registered nurse now.
-Hey! There you go.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
So, I was like, "Safe.
I'll give her the dog."
And then I came back.
Same thing happened.
The dog was really in love
with my sister and not me.
So I bought a third dog, and now
she's with me all the time.
-Now, what kind of dog
is this dog?
-I'm allergic to all dogs,
so they all have to be a poodle
or, like, a poodle mix.
-Right.
-So they're all
poodles and, like --
-Poodle-doodles?
-Yeah.
They're really --
They're like this big.
They so cute.
And this one -- This one, I
think, is going to stay with me.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Now you've got three dogs.
-Yeah.
-What are their names?
-Mabel, Henry, and Lock.
-Yeah.
-Those are great names.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I like straight-up names
for a dog.
-I like straight-up,
regular names, like Joe.
-Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, my dog is Gary.
-Yeah. It's so funny.
-I love it. Yeah. Why not?
-"What's up, Gary?"
-Yeah, Gary.
It's like,
"Gary, get over here."
It's, like, some cute
golden retriever coming over.
I want to ask you quickly.
I know you're getting ready
to work on a couple of projects,
but one project you're working
on I'm very excited about.
You're going to play
Joey Ramone?
-Yes. That is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Thank you. Yeah.
I would also be
hesitant to clap, as well.
-No.
-No, it's the craziest thing.
It was like a year or two ago,
I got a call.
They were like, "Would you like
to play Joey Ramone?"
And I was like, "Yeah."
-Of course.
-But I thought
it wasn't, like, a real thing.
And then it became a real thing.
So now, yeah, hopefully
in January or February,
we'll start.
-This is amazing, buddy.
I never heard you sing.
-I can't.
-There you go. This is perfect.
-As a joke -- This is true.
Three years ago,
I started taking
singing lessons as a joke,
because I --
No, I just thought it would be
funny if, like, one day, like,
I was just hanging out
with the boys
and, like --
And just belted out a song.
-I know what
you're talking about.
-Yeah, you know?
-That would be a good bit.
-Just kicking it
with the boys in the most
un-song-friendly environment
and then just belt out, like,
Sinatra or something.
Yeah, so,
I've been going to this --
For like a year,
I went to this guy who --
He's a voice coach of the stars.
-Wow!
-And I remember
going up to his apartment,
and he was like,
"This is so great.
This is cool
we get to work together."
He's like,
"What project is this for?"
And I was like,
"This is for my pure enjoyment."
-Nothing. I'm just here to hang
and learn something.
-I can't sing yet,
but I know what
it's supposed to sound like.
-Alright, good.
-Yeah.
-I can't wait for that.
I think it's going to be great.
-Oh, one day,
I will belt it out.
-Yeah.
-I want to talk about
this Sunday.
Madison Square Garden,
"NYC Still Rising After
20 Years: A Comedy Celebration."
Listen to all these comedians
that are going to be
at the Garden this Sunday.
Amy Schumer, Bill Burr,
Colin Jost, Colin Quinn,
Dave Attell, Dave Chappelle,
John Mulaney, Jon Stewart,
Michael Che.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm going to be there.
-Jimmy's going to be there.
-I'm gonna be -- Yeah.
-Yep.
Thank you. I appreciate that.
-Very nice of you to --
You know,
I know you're a busy guy,
so thanks for doing that.
-Are you kidding me?
You sent me a text and you go,
"Well, I might put this thing on
with Jon,
and would you be interested?"
And I go, "Anything."
Obviously, for the
city and for you, I'd do it.
But, I mean,
was it hard to get all these --
This is --
-The lineup is nuts.
Yeah, it's like
the Avengers and me.
No, it was --
It was really cool.
Me and Jon
just reached out to --
Luckily,
we have really great friends,
and we reached out,
and everybody was
super-stoked to do it.
And it was just like --
You know,
it's obviously, like,
a thing that's, like,
close to me and stuff,
so I got --
A lot of people
wanted to do, like, a thing,
like some sort of, like --
you know, like,
an article or, like --
And it all
just felt really weird.
So I just called Jon
and I was like,
"We should do something fun,
like a fun little party,
and, like,
just have a good time."
So that's how it came together.
And he does a lot, you know,
for firemen and a lot for
the city, so it was just --
-Yeah, and all the proceeds are
going to go to 9/11 charities,
I should say, so --
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Very cool.
-I can't wait.
I'm honored to be part of it.
I love that you put it together.
That's awesome.
I can't wait to
see you on Sunday.
"NYC Still Rising After
20 Years: A Comedy Celebration"
is happening this Sunday
at Madison Square Garden.
Tickets are available now.
More with Pete Davidson
when we come back. Stick around.